le compromis allemand un confinement qui
misent sur le civisme des citoyens sans
attestation aux limites géographiques de
déplacement mais avec la fermeture des
salles de sports bars restaurants et
lieux de culture et ce pour tout le mois
de novembre
cela signifie que c'est entre les mains
de chacun de faire de ce mois de
novembre
notre succès commun de parvenir à un
tournant pour retrouver une traçabilité
de la pandémie
et si nous parvenons au cours des quatre
prochaines semaines à ralentir la
circulation du virus alors nous aurons
les conditions nécessaires à un mois de
décembre supportable en suivant bien sûr
encore les règles contre le coronavirus
comme nous les connaissons depuis
plusieurs mois déjà mais avec plus de
liberté à mairie d'airé section
indispensable selon les autorités il
faut dire que les indicateurs ne sont
pas rassurants les soins intensifs ont
vu le nombre de patientes doublé en une
dizaine de jours alors que la barre des
quinze mille nouveaux cas quotidiens a
été atteinte la semaine passée des
mesures nécessaires donc mais pas
toujours facile à accepter
suscitant des réactions variées
outre-rhin je pense qu'il est juste
d'avoir mis en place confinement léger
parce que ce n'est pas un hasard c'est
les chiffres ont grimpé en flèche
le gouvernement doit s'assurer qu'il
protège ses citoyens et que le nombre
d'infections diminuent à nouveau
je ne pense pas qu'ils essaient de nous
avoir il n'y a pas tant de restrictions
que ça mais c'est la clientèle qui
manquent
nous les chauffeurs de vélos taxis nous
avons un manque à gagner de 50 à 60% sur
notre chiffre d'affaires cette année et
ça c'est un impact sur notre vie
personnelle je trouve que le confinement
n'est pas assez différencier nous avons
beaucoup de place ici et en hiver nous
avons la possibilité d'aérer avec des
fenêtres à l'avant et à l'arrière du
restaurant et je n'avais donc pas
vraiment besoin de fermer comme partout
en europe les allemands redoutent les
conséquences économiques et sociales de
ces restrictions
et même si de nouveaux efforts sont
demandés un espoir subsiste celui d'un
noël entouré de ses proches